la función dos veces diferenciable efe y
su segunda derivada fbi prima se
grafican a continuación lo puedes ver
aquí de hecho estoy trabajando en un
artículo en la can academia en español
que se llama justificación mediante la
segunda derivada podemos ver aquí a efe
de color azul ya mi prima de color
anaranjado y el problema continúa así a
cuatro estudiantes se les pidió dar una
justificación apropiada con base en el
cálculo para garantizar que f es cóncava
hacia arriba cuando x es mayor que 1
entonces veamos si estamos de acuerdo
con esta afirmación cuando x es más
grande que 1 podemos ver que fbi prima
es mayor que 0 es positiva lo que nos
dicen que f es cóncava hacia arriba en
ese intervalo
es decir nuestra pendiente de la recta
tangente se mantiene creciendo y puedes
ver que la segunda derivada
antes que x igual a 1 es negativa y en x
igual a 10 pero a nosotros nos interesa
qué es lo que pasa cuando x es mayor que
1 y observa efe mi prima es positiva y
se mantiene creciendo así que en efecto
podemos ver que en el intervalo donde x
es mayor que 1 la función f es cóncava
hacia arriba recuerda la justificación
con base en el cálculo de que en ese
intervalo tenemos una concavidad hacia
arriba es que tenemos la segunda
derivada positiva en este intervalo
porque es la segunda derivada es
positiva la primera derivada está
creciendo y por lo tanto la función
original es cóncava hacia arriba con
base en esto me preguntan puedes
emparejar los comentarios del profesor
con las justificaciones ahora veamos las
justificaciones de los alumnos e
intentemos dar los mejores comentarios a
estas justificaciones
lo haría el profesor la primera dice la
gráfica de f tiene forma de tazón es
decir una y bueno eso es cierto pero no
es una justificación matemática
necesitamos usar el conocimiento que nos
da la segunda derivada así que pondré
esta no es una justificación con base en
el cálculo
la segunda dice la segunda derivada de f
está sobre el eje x cuando x es mayor
que 1 bueno eso es exactamente lo que
decíamos si la segunda derivada de f
está sobre el eje x es decir es positiva
significa que mi primera derivada está
creciendo y que mi función
efe tiene una concavidad hacia arriba
por lo tanto esta es una justificación
con base en el cálculo así que pondré
muy bien estás en lo correcto la tercera
justificación dice es positiva esto es
muy ambiguo cuál es positiva si el
alumno escribe esto entonces el profesor
se podría preguntar cuál es positiva la
función es positiva o la primera
derivada es positiva o la segunda
derivada es positiva así que el
comentario que yo pondría
por favor utiliza un lenguaje más
preciso esta respuesta no puede
aceptarse como una justificación
correcta y la última dice la segunda
derivada de f es creciente cuando x es
mayor que 1 ojo eso no justifica que
tengamos una concavidad hacia arriba
por ejemplo la segunda derivada es
creciente antes de x igual a 1 y no
tenemos una concavidad hacia arriba de
hecho tenemos una concavidad hacia abajo
entonces pondré esto no justifica el
hecho de que sea cóncava hacia arriba y
hemos terminado hasta la próxima